I always slip into a mild Boston accent
with you because you are from the old
boss him old boss in town from the hunt
Massachusetts no ha ha ha
also sounds like how you turned down the
Keystone Light Keystone teach the people
because I use it all the time yeah your
touchstone to get into a Boston accent
cuz you taught it to me oh yeah and I
said you mind if I say that on stage on
my podcast no no yeah and I gave you
free will right but I want people to
know it's you oh it's all me do it Tommy
there's just basically two words to get
into a Boston accent my favorite and
they are the words burglar and smuggler
it's not cop it's not can't have it yes
that gets you nowhere and it's burglar
oh my god I came home the other night
there was a burglar in my house he stole
on my drugs he must be some kind of drug
smuggler ah sure is that we can you were
you on best week ever I was told you
were too dark I was and a man be cool
camping is weird I find the idea of just
rather than a board just like panic
abort
take me to the brown road you can tell
the consistency that would have been it
to like oh my god you know what YouTube
jack for best week ever yeah yeah that's
the that's the doc you might want to
audition for West whereas we get up no I
know I did best we give her a bunch of
times and then I was there what's told
that's right because we never crossed
paths at that pool now I was told that
this the jokes that I was writing were
too mean were to me that that my tone
was too dark for the show really wanted
like real celebrations of how people
were behaving real bad and I was like
and I was just like very harsh
I was basically like shaming trying to
shame anybody I could like just like how
dare you Britney Spears whenever we were
talking about I I remember but you had
to do it with a wink and a smile be like
I think it's great that Britney hey hey
I couldn't do that
yeah yeah I couldn't do that would be
like for shame I should have been are
you alright not really
what are we just realized to just like
cough in the middle of it yeah but get
it together you have a television show
[Music]